cuáles son los puntos clave que han
llevado a esta cifra de desaprobación y
qué retos se enfrenta castillo para
intentar revertirla
buenas tardes gracias rodrigo por
invitación bueno el presidente llegue a
esta alta cifra de esta aprobación
con algunos problemas en gobierno no
sólo a nivel de gestión sino también a
nivel judicial porque enfrenta tres
investigaciones preliminares en la
thalía
dos de ellas entonces díaz pérez indica
pertenecer a una organización criminal
tenemos también una problemática social
debido a bueno la crisis externa el
incremento a los combustibles pero es
relacionando un poco digamos el contexto
en que llega esa situación y la puesta
por ejemplo encuesta señala que la
mayoría de gente está preocupada por lo
que es en seguridad ciudad entonces
justamente este es uno de los retos lo
que también tiene el presidente él ha
adelantado que va a hacer un anuncio una
sorpresa en su mensaje de por primer año
el gobierno es la incertidumbre también
en el estado
si la encuesta muestra también que perú
sigue dividido en torno a la figura
presidencial en el mundo rural su
desaprobación es sólo del 55 por ciento
frente al 87% por ejemplo en lima pese a
ello es una mala cifra para el gobierno
ha desatendido castillo a quienes lo
auparon a la presidencia o más bien sus
políticas sociales y hacia el campo no
han sido todo lo exitosas que pretendían
el problema con presión de castilla que
se queda en lo que es el discurso en el
vamos a hacer y ustedes puede escuchar
los discursos que ven las actividades
que hacen las regiones en el interior
del país parece un candidato o parte que
todavía no hubiera salido de la campaña
electoral y eso también se siente en la
población en electro de país como bien
decía en el estudio del país todavía
tiene un bastión importante pero cada
vez agradeciendo este apoyo él llegó con
una promesa por ejemplo en la reforma
del área y al momento no hay ninguna
política concreta al respecto llegó con
una serie de discursos de apoyo a la
población o una figura de identificación
con el peso de la población pero
prácticamente hechos concretos medidas
concretas no hay por qué su gestión
el problema de elegir a funcionar que es
adecuado también le ha impedido
completar políticas públicas importantes
para el país si esta encuesta muestra
también que la desaprobación al congreso
en general es del 79 por ciento han
dejado los peruanos de creer en su clase
política y en que podría desembocar esta
desafección
bueno esa es una historia que
arrastramos ya en los últimos años que
cada vez presenta más esta crisis
política tenemos la problemática por un
lado del ejecutivo por otro tenemos como
bien dices el congreso y bueno es una
alta desaprobación pero hay un detalle
de la encuesta también señala que 65%
está de acuerdo con un eventual adelanto
de elecciones generales una medida que
es el congreso no sé no te quiere
aplicar
mucha gente dice también por intereses
personales estamos en este ciclo en ese
círculo vicioso de enfrentamientos entre
poderes pero también de falta de
decisión desde ambos hace poco nada más
el congreso casi pone en riesgo las
celebraciones de asamblea de la oea por
un tema de unos baños ni personales
digamos discusiones creo muy tontas para
lo que necesita el país entonces éste lo
que justamente estaba expresando a la
gente es en esta desafección nos pero
con el ejecutivo sino también con el
congreso y ya al cumplirse un año de la
gestión de ambos poderes justamente
esperamos algún tiempo de medidas en
este sentido de acuerdo lo que han
planteado algunos artistas y si no y si
no medidas incompletas para encaminar de
una vez del país